harry's est un qui ont plus ou moins
entendu le message du gouvernement sur
le confinement bien car ils étaient
nombreux à vouloir quitter la capitale
on retrouve en direct depuis la gare
montparnasse montparnasse à notre
reporter natacha perat sac manège
bonjour alors hier on a vu beaucoup de
français qui tentait de quitter la
capitale vous êtes sur le parvis de la
gare montparnasse qu'en est il
aujourd'hui
écoutez doha ils sont quand même on peut
le dire assez nombreux en ces voyageurs
à vouloir quitter la capitale forcément
qui dit train d'y voyageur vous l'avez
dit ils étaient des milliers hier avoir
quitté la capitale ils sont encore
nombreux depuis ce matin et bien à
entrer dans cette gare montparnasse
pourrait bien se prendre des trains en
direction d'angers nantes bordeaux ou
encore poitiers l'objectif pour eux est
bien c'est de se mettre à l'abri auprès
de familles d'amis ou alors de se rendre
dans leur résidence secondaire
alors si beaucoup de ces voyageurs sont
conscients de leur comportement
dangereux puisque et bien ses
déplacements ses voyages favorisent la
propagation du virus beaucoup d'entre
eux estiment ne pas avoir le choix je
vous propose d'en écouter quelques uns
je suis rentré chez moi en fait parce
que c'est quand dira c'était un lieu
temporaire et du coup je suis la russie
grâce ici donc je vais rentrer chez moi
non je rejoins pas ma famille justement
j'ai pris le choix d'être un peu mais
confiné seul mais justement parce que
prévis t de contaminer ma famille mes
proches travaillent dans le milieu
hospitalier
déjà première mission j'ai mes enfants
mais ils sont chez la maman
donc je vais rentrer chez moi il ya je
vais attendre j'ai la température à
prendre régulièrement voir si j'ai pas
de températures et ensuite je téléphone
à mon service voir ce que je peux faire
est ce que détestent affaires ou autres
et ensuite je verrai fait deux trois
jours j'essaye de rentrer chez moi à
bordeaux et que j'arrive pas parce que
tous les trains sont complets
les avions aussi pour louer une voiture
aussi c'était une galère du coup là
c'est le seul qui va du coup je vais
mettre en quarantaine à bordeaux c'est
juste que j'ai pu de quoi rester à paris
j'ai juste pas trop le choix
non maintenant juste ma famille à
bordeaux
j'étais là pour passer un week end et
faut que je rentre
et on le sait dans les régions jusqu'ici
épargné par le coronavirus pourrait donc
être rapidement contaminés par l'arrivée
massive de ces parisiens qui est bien
recherche à se mettre au vert pendant 15
jours 15 jours c'est le temps minimum
annoncé en par emmanuel macron pour bien
mettre ces mesures en place des mesures
drastiques des mesures de confinement
même s'il n'a jamais prononcé ce mot là
le président de la république
on le sait et c'est important de le
rappeler on peut être porteur de la
maladie sans le constater enfin
constater le moindre symptôme et c'est
là où est le problème puisque cette
maladie se coronavirus il est
extrêmement contagieux alors si les
forces de l'ordre hier et bien ont
favorisé la pédagogie ainsi l'on se sont
attelés surtout à expliquer les
consignes aux riverains aujourd'hui à
ses forces de l'ordre devraient se
montrer un peu plus strictes puisque
toute personne n'ayant pas le droit de
circuler un bien sera verbalisé dans
montant de 38 euros à la suite se
montant à 7 à monde évoluera vers un
montant plus important 135 euros damende
vous le voyez derrière moi peut-être on
a plusieurs fourgons de police beaucoup
de patrouille de police est bien qu'ils
procèdent à des contrôles d'identité et
bien qu'ils vérifient que chaque passant
et le droit le droit de circuler que
c'est que ces personnes aussi et bien
sont en possession de cette fameuse
attestation sur l'honneur qu'ils aient
bien permet de circuler
l'objectif de ces mesures drastiques on
va appelle ses d'endiguer cette
propagation du virus du coroner virus
qui fait des dégâts considérables en
france 1 175 morts et à plus de 7000
personnes contaminées depuis le début
en direct du parvis de la gare
montparnasse merci pour toutes ces
précisions et par